so it was a good question that how the
whole India India where which lesson
village or India lives and urban India
the real minimum of Cana me is only when
every Indian is being benefited by this
economic growth
so what I believed strongly is that we
have to think big we have to think that
there is a system which is populated of
1.2 billion people and how this people
can sustain and how these people can
participate in to the economic process
so if we raise this question that means
there has to be a mechanism in which
Indians and large has to be participate
in to economic growth and it has to be
inclusive growth so the first step is
about
the theme by which India has to grow
whether it is manufacturing or just
agriculture or it is a mix of a
combination of economy and are we going
to be the pure service industry or soft
economy are going to be the hard economy
or the mix of the hard and soft and then
the question arises do we have an
educator infrastructure can we connect
people to the menacing can a person
living in village require the same
facility what a person lives in city can
acquire and how fast they can do that
and whether they can afford that one
that means in macro infrastructure has
to be thought of for the country and
this is what I can give you an example
like what's happened what's going to
happen between delhi and mumbai as a
industrial corridor and freight corridor
which will bring in a very systematic
way a new in the shul khurshid culture
to India it will give millions of jobs
to to give a new job should be swap
engines and outside of India as well so
similarly we can think of other coil
goes like agriculture corridor between
ilion Calcutta
and where we can think of a systematic
production of Agriculture by bringing
some value of say processing packaging
logistics preservation and similarly we
can think of affiliating Indians into
the similar mackerel with the macro
thought process the education
agriculture infrastructure and many
traumatic economic processes when they
start and they integrate at a place I
think this will take care of the whole
country and it will involve lot of
people whether they're at the bottom
lying on with on the owner made of the
top here so we have to think macro and
king pig because our country indeed is a
very big country
you know it has a population of 1.2
billion thank you